the eight news now investigators
continue to try to get answers from
leaders at the Nevada Department of
Corrections thank you for joining us at
six I'm Brian Loftus I'm Denise Valdez
this as a hunger strike is taking place
inside a state prison right now Vanessa
Murphy has more on what unfolded today
as inmates loved ones are now pleading
for help as a parent it kills me Nina
Fernandez says her son is taking part in
a hunger strike at Ely State Prison to
demand better conditions he's serving
time for stealing a car along with a
habitual criminal charge he said Mom if
I never make it out just know I loved
you and that's sad to say to our parents
for your child to come to you and say
something like that that's terrible as
the 8 news now investigators first
reported the hunger strike began on
December 1st numerous inmates have been
telling us sufficient Medical Care and
food aren't being provided inside state
prisons while there are conflicting
reports about just how many inmates are
taking part in the hunger strike on
Friday the Nevada Department of
Corrections said 24 were refusing to eat
19 of them for nine days how concerned
is the department about the hunger
strike
very concerned Brian Williams's endoc's
deputy director of programs he stepped
outside this endoc facility where
inmates loved ones and their supporters
gathered Friday as someone who's part of
leadership here our Nevada state prisons
in a crisis
I don't say crisis we are understaffed
we don't have the resources to do the
things that we need to do but we are
working through that loved ones and
advocacy groups are pleading for outside
agencies to step in the whole big thing
is getting the help that we need for our
inmates speaking out getting the help
our voices need to be heard and they're
not endoc announcing Friday in a news
release it will clarify the process of
disciplinary action against inmates a
small step in a state agency with major
failures including the Escape of a
convicted murderer inmate suicides and
murders and a riot which the department
downplayed until we exposed it can we
have a promise from you that you'll be
more transparent that the department
will be more transparent I believe we
are being transparent do you think
anything he said was satisfactory I
think it's all lies ndoc says it's
working to resolve the hunger strike and
monitoring the health and weight of the
inmates like Fernandez's son Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now
so a major challenge at the ndoc of
course is Staffing as you heard there in
that piece the department offers much
lower pay though compared with nearby
law enforcement agencies